>> Sean: GETTING BACK TO OUR
STOP STORY.
ROBERT MUELLER'S TEAM ON DEFENSE
TONIGHT.
REALLY SERIOUS CLAIMS.
THE FBI PRESSURING GENERAL FLYNN
TO BE INTERVIEWED WITHOUT AN
ATTORNEY PRESENT.
THAT HAS GOTTEN THE ATTENTION OF
JUDGE EMMETT SULLIVAN.
HE ORDERED MUELLER TO HAND OVER
ALL DOCUMENTS REPLATED TO THE
FLYNN INTERVIEW BY 3:00 P.M.
TOMORROW AND THEN WE HAVE JAMES
COMEY BOASTING UP THAT WE TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THE SITUATION THAT
WE DID THIS THIS WAS A NEW
ADMINISTRATION.
WE DON'T HAVE DONE IT IMPORTANT
OBAMA AND BUSH.
REALLY?
HERE'S CHERYL ATKINSON.
IS THIS HOW WE TREAT AMERICAN
HEROS THAT WE BRAG, OH, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I WOULDN'T HAVE
DONE OR GOTTEN AWAY WITH A MORE
ORGANIZED ADMINISTRATION LIKE
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION.
SO I TOOK FULL ADVANTAGE.
ON TOP OF THE DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR TELLING FLYNN HE
DOESN'T NEED A LAWYER.
THEY WANTED HIM RELAXED.
MEANWHILE, BECAUSE OF THE
UNMASKING AND THE LEAKING OF RAW
INTELLIGENCE, SOMETHING THAT
CHERYL ATKINSON KNOWS ABOUT
PERSONALLY, THEY HAD A DIRECT
TRANSCRIPT THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE
HAD, CONGRESSMAN.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: WHEN DOES THIS END?
WHEN DO THESE PEOPLE GET HELD
ACCOUNTABLE?
INSTEAD OF THE PEOPLE WITH THE
TAXI MEDALLIONS AND LOAN
APPLICATIONS?
>> THAT'S WHY WE NEED A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
YOU'RE SO RIGHT, SEAN.
WHEN YOU SAY I GOT AWAY WITH
SOMETHING, THAT TELLS YOU YOU
DIDN'T DO IT THE RIGHT WAY.
YOU DIDN'T FOLLOW THE RULES.
YOU DIDN'T DO IT THE WAY YOU
WERE SUPPOSED TO.
THEY WERE SO FOCUSED ON GETTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THAT THEY WERE
WILLING TO SET UP A LIEUTENANT
GENERAL.
A GUY THAT SERVED OUR COUNTRY 33
YEARS.
SO THAT'S THE MOST EGREGIOUS
PART OF THIS, WHAT THEY DID TO
GENERAL FLYNN.
THE OTHER THING TO UNDERSTAND
IS, MIKE FLYNN RAN THE DEFENSE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
HE HAD TO KNOW HIS CONVERSATIONS
WITH KISLYAK WERE BEING
MONITORED.
HE HAD TO KNOW THAT.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR HIM TO SAY
SOMETHING THAT WASN'T TRUE.
HE GOT CAUGHT BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
KNOW THAT THEY WERE SETTING HIM
UP LIKE THEY DID.
THE JUDGE DEMANDED THESE
DOCUMENTS IS EXACTLY WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN.
>> Sean: THE DYNAMIC TRIO,
COMEY, McCABE AND STRZOK, CHERYL
ATKINSON.
YOU CAN RELATE TO THIS IN YOUR
OWN WAY, ESPECIALLY UNMASKING
SURVEILLANCE ISSUES.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, I CAN'T
BELIEVE THIS HAS HAPPENED IN OUR
COUNTRY.
I DON'T CARE WHERE YOU STAND IN
THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
>> I THINK YOU'RE GETTING AT
WHAT IS THE BIGGER STORY, REALLY
AND IS UNDERREPORTED IN TERMS OF
HOW BIG IT IS.
WHICH IS, THE SURVEILLANCE AND
OTHER ALLEGED ABUSES IMPLEMENTED
BY SOME BAD ACTORS IN OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THE PROBLEM IS, I'M GLAD JUDGE
SULLIVAN IS FLIRTING AROUND THE
EDGES OF THIS IN THE FLYNN CASE.
BUT WHO ULTIMATELY DOES ANYTHING
ABOUT IT?
BECAUSE THOSE ACCUSED AS IN THE
GOVERNMENT COMPUTER INTRUSIONS
TO ME ARE THOSE THAT HAVE THE
PROSECUTORIAL AUTHORITY.
IF THEY DON'T AGREE TO PROSECUTE
THEMSELVES, WHERE DO YOU TURN IN
THIS?
>> Sean: I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
REMEDY THIS, BETWEEN -- THEY'RE
ALL THE SAME CHARACTERS IN THIS
PLAY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S STRZOK AND COMEY
WRITING AN EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION.
THE BIGGEST SLAM DUNK CASE WITH
THE E-MAIL SERVER AND NOT
RESPONDING WITH A SUBPOENA AND
ERASING AND THE FISA ABUSE.
JAMES COMEY'S ADMISSION, THEY
DIDN'T VET IT BUT HE PUT HIS
SIGNATURE ON IT, TO SPY ON A
CANDIDATE.
COMMITTED A FRAUD AGAINST THE
FISA COURT.
THEY DON'T TELL A JUDGE.
MAY HAVE A POLITICAL TAINT TO
IT.
THAT'S NOT HOW THINGS ARE
SUPPOSED TO WORK UNDER THIS
CONSTITUTION, UNDER OUR FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> HE SAID IN A DEPOSITION LAST
WEEK THAT HE DIDN'T KNOW THEY
HAD A LEGAL DUTY TO PRESENT
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION TO THE
FISA JUDGE.
OF COURSE YOU HAVE TO DO THAT.
FOR THE HEAD OF THE FBI TO SAY
THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE A DUTY TO DO
THAT IS SCARY.
THE OTHER THING I COME BACK TO,
SEAN, NEVER FORGET THE BIAS THAT
EXISTS WITH THE KEY PEOPLE.
McCABE, COMEY, STRZOK AND PAIGE.
MID YEAR EXAM: THEY KNEW THEY
WOULD GET IT TAKEN CARE OF.
GET IT THROUGH THE MID YEAR.
WHAT WAS THE NAME THAT THEY GAVE
THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION?
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE.
JUST THE NAME TO SHOW YOU THE
BIAS WAS THERE FROM THE GET-GO
WITH THESE TOP OF PEOPLE AT THE
FBI THAT RAN BOTH
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Sean: CHERYL, LOOK WHAT THEY
DID IN ALL OF THESE CASES HERE.
THEY'RE INVOLVED, THE SAME
CHARACTERS, THE SAME PLAYERS,
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT HAD A BIAS.
THEY DID THIS ON WEEK ONE OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
SOUNDS LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY
TO ME.
SOUNDS LIKE A MEDIA LEAK
STRATEGY IS COMING THERE AFTER.
>> IT SOUND LIKE AN OPERATION.
SOMETHING THAT WE LEARNED FROM
COMEY, I THOUGHT THIS WAS
PLOWING OLD GROUND TO LOOK BACK
AT THE CLINTON MATERIAL.
IN LIGHT OF WHAT HE SAID, COMEY
SAID IN HIS TESTIMONY LORETTA
LYNCH, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
SHOULD HAVE RECUSED HERSELF AND
SHOULD BE.
NOT JUST FROM THE TARMAC MEETING
BUT OTHER UNNAMED MATERIAL THAT
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
NUMBER 2, HE SAID HE HAD KNOWN
ABOUT AGENT STRZOK AND PAGE'S
TEXTS, HE WOULDN'T HAVE LET THEM
STAY ON THE INVETTESGATION THAT
THEY DID ON CLINTON.
>> Sean: THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THEY WIPED CLEAN THE PHONES
OF STRZOK AND PAGE WHEN HE
WORKED FOR MUELLER.